on est sur le dernier trou du parcours
la creuse s'appelle la foule
la poule pourquoi parce que
habituellement dernier trou il ya
toujours beaucoup de monde qui suit les
dernières parties donc là c'est un par 4
qui est un des trous les plus difficiles
de par ses moyens des scores à l'open de
france qu'on peut trouver sur le circuit
européen c'est un long par 4 qui fait
431 m bull a encore une fois de la mise
en jeu va être primordial pourquoi parce
que non encore de l'obstacle d'eau cette
fois ci sur la partie gauche du fairway
et on a également sur la partie droite
des bunkers qu'on ne voit pas du départ
mise à part celui qui est là extrémités
droite et qui attendent qu'une seule
chose c'est de recevoir les balles de
façon à rendre la tacc de green mais
injouable
ou alors si le joueur prend le risque
prend des risques assez conséquent et
qui peut avoir des conséquences assez
dramatique pour l'issue d'un match
donc là le deuxième coup une fois que le
voir à millas la balle ici sur la mise
en jeu 2e poule n'est pas donné et a
toujours le vent qui pousse un peu
légèrement contre sur ce coup là assez
régulièrement donc qui rallongent quand
même le trou et surtout l'obstacle
d'autres est devant avec le green qui
fuit un tout petit peu pourquoi parce
que en fait le green est beaucoup plus
étroit sur la partie droite ce qui veut
dire que un coût qui sera pas forcément
bien toucher un club pas forcément bien
choisi avec le vent qui pousse à droite
avec une balle qui sera peut-être pas
forcément touché formidablement bien
le coût sera quand même pénalisé avec
avec l'obstacle d'eau devant
[Musique]
ce green du trou numéro 18 est un green
très compliquée à jouer pourquoi parce
que si on n'a pas joué une attaque d une
proche du drapeau avec toutes les pentes
qu'on peut y trouver
on peut facilement facilement prendre 1
3 voire un peu plus de 3 peu de sueur
sur ce green l'a pas oublié certains
joueurs encore une fois en relation avec
l'open de france qui ont perdu des
tombants ici tout simplement parce que
trop loin du drapeau parce que pas assez
attentif sur les pentes et se sont
retrouvés sur des dents dépositions de
deux fuyards les tournois ou abandonnés
c'est vraiment beaucoup trop loin du
tout pour le gagner
donc là maintenant ce qu'il faut c'est
attendre avec impatience les joueurs qui
vont les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux les
24 meilleurs mondiaux qui vont venir qui
vont venir à la fin du mois à battre le
faire pour gagner ce trophée magique
qu'est la ryder cup sur ce magnifique
parcours qui est le parcours de
l'albatros
[Musique]